you remember them our vertical axis is
that's about movement right
whereas this horizontal start again the
vertical axis is about displacement
whereas this horizontal axis is about
time okay now it depends on the question
as to what kind of movement this is
right I know on the graph it looks up
and down but it might be left or right
okay
now I'm actually gonna deal with the
left or right case because I think that
when it's up or down it's very easy it's
obvious to describe you can say the
particle goes up the card the tennis
ball the Apple goes up or down right
but going left to right is a bit less
intuitive so that's what I'm going to go
with and I'm gonna give you this work
the devil okay so where do we begin a
question might be um describe the motion
question okay and this is you know
almost universally this is like a pop3
or a power 4 and after you've done all
of the calculus find the stationary
points find the points of oppression
blah blah blah blah they say okay
hence describe the motion of the
particle okay now you can see by the way
this example it's got a definite end it
doesn't always sometimes you'll go on
forever and you have to still describe
it in those terms but we'll just take
this as our first example okay this is
gonna be long by the way so those of you
who don't like to do lots of writing
like those of you avoid doing concluding
statements when you're finishing like a
rate of change problem okay and you're
not gonna like this but deal with it
okay so we start at the beginning
okay I would say the particle begins now
like I said this could be anything okay
whatever object you're dealing with how
do begins now I'm at two here
okay positive two and I said that at the
beginning I'm dealing with left right
now by convention there's no common
sense reason why it's just people
decided positive means to the right and
negative means to the left I mean it
just as easily could have been the other
way around but this is what everyone
does and if we all are on the same page
that's good so that means the particle
begins
and I'm just going to stick with units
it might be meters or kilometers or
whatever two units to the right of now
later on we gonna talk a bit more about
what the origin signifies the argue
could be anything you like the origin
could be the ground it could be some
arbitrary point in the air if they don't
say anything else about it you just say
the origin okay but if it does have if
the origin does have some kind of
physical significance it's the ground or
the top of a tree or the top of a cliff
or a building or something like that you
do you actually have to say that okay
because you'll become at the toilet lid
or the particle begins to so right in
your origin so I described its position
now I need to say what it's doing okay
so sometimes a particle would begin and
it'll be stationary this particle is not
what's it doing
how would you water last two different
things number one which way is it going
right we're only talking about one
dimensional motion okay so it's this or
that right right or left so the option
is left right it's going that way okay
it is initially moving to the left now
that's not all you can say about its
motion apart from its direction
you also can describe something about
its velocity right namely that I've
tried to draw this as a straight line
right so I would say it's initially
moving to the left at a constant
velocity now depending on how much
information you've worked out in the
prior parts of the question that will
kind of decide for you how much detail
you're going to put here okay for
instance because you're you know this
interceptor that intercept you can tell
me what is that velocity should probably
say what that's there it goes from two
to the origin in one time unit
oh it's for one second okay let's go two
seconds so therefore it's traveling up
what's me two units per second
right
okay now the next thing it keeps doing
that and then there's an important
feature namely an intercept right so I
would say it passes the origin or maybe
after one second it passes the origin
some people call this life kind of
optional because nothing about the
motion of the particle has changed but
because it's an important feature I
think you might as well put it in some
people think it's really important okay
now what's the next important thing that
happens it stops right now actually I
think I did this coordinate wrong that
should be probably minus two right
I was trying to fit scale but then I
realized that wouldn't make them
constants so after two seconds what does
it do it what does it do it stops right
where does it stop
so you've got a you know Y value here Y
value is about displacement a bad
position right I would say it stops two
meters two units sorry two units to the
left okay now what does it do while it's
there it remains there for another
second right you can take it remain
stationary okay now like I said this is
getting along right we haven't got that
far
okay it starts to move again which
direction does it move it
it starts whipping through the right
feels real time right doing that but
this is why I actually write this for
myself okay so that I know I can talk
about it okay it starts moving sorry
she's at time after three seconds it's
not
okay now just like before we describe
its velocity and we said it was constant
okay it's not constant anymore and
actually the vast majority of the kinds
of motion situations you'd be looking at
the motion is not constant usually it's
slowing down
or it's speeding up okay so how do you
describe it it's moving to the right and
it's there remember I said don't talk in
terms of out of deceleration okay that's
a bad idea if you want to say something
gets slowed up say it gets slower okay
here it gets faster okay so it starts
moving to the right and it's speed
increases okay now before I talk about
the end of this speed increase okay
it also passes the origin after five
seconds
you can say it passes again suppose that
part so important okay now at this point
here now geometrically what kind of
point is it from calculus like in year
11 you would have said that's a point of
inflection okay but we need to talk
about what that signifies in terms of
motion okay so a point of inflection
means what's happening from here to here
my direction hasn't changed that my
speed has changed I'm getting faster and
faster and faster and faster until I hit
the point inflection okay so how would
you say how would your word the
significance of this point in terms of
the motion in terms of house movements
now that's where acceleration stops
right because remember acceleration is a
second derivative
okay and appointment flexion is where
your second derivative is zero okay so
you can say how'd you pass the
originator after at five and a half
seconds now you've got two ways to says
you can say the particle stops
accelerating okay but if you go down
that path you have to say something else
because acceleration right just like
velocity and just like this placement is
a vector okay so you can't just say
accelerate you have to say which way
okay because actually the truth is it
doesn't really stop accelerating it just
starts accelerating in another direction
okay so I'm gonna say the panhu stops
accelerating toward the right okay now
an alternative way to say that which I
don't know we should prefer they're both
equivalent though is to say the particle
reaches its maximum speed
okay can you see that to reach a maximum
speed and to stop accelerating actually
really the same thing okay now I'm gonna
keep talking about acceleration because
the acceleration changes okay if the
particle begins to accelerate toward the
left okay
so that's why I left with acceleration
while traveling to the right slows you
down it is to accelerate toward the left
okay
again another way of saying that is it
slows down the particle begins to slow
down now we're almost there
the last feature is another stationary
point okay and just like these points
down here stationary means it's
stationary it's not moving okay so the
particle you could say either stops
moving or the language that you're here
is the particle comes to rest you want
to say two things when it comes to rest
and web right after seven seconds
five units to the right
exhale now you like do I have to provide
back much every time the answer is if
you have a function that complex yes
okay now to be fair usually your
functions are not this bad I made it
pretty messy so that I could draw out
and explain all the different parts of
it okay we'll look at some other
examples too